hey guys this is dennis the founder
think Cara and I'm David Griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of Breaking Bad
the the final season confessions episode
11 third one since we've been back yep
yeah so this is the episode where the
[ __ ] hits the fan yes like we're kind of
what we've been waiting for I guess cuz
we've been talking and speculum
eventually Jesse's gonna turn mud Walt
but we didn't know was he gonna find out
about Jane was gonna fight about the
ricin was gonna fight about Mike what
was the thing that was gonna convince
him to turn right and now we know yeah
you know he's mad Jesse's upset he's not
happy obviously we see him at the end
they're going with the gasoline or
whatever and trying to possibly burn
Walt's house down if that's going to
happen but we've already seen what
Walt's house collects in the future but
who knows leah was great this is other
great episode I mean probably had one of
the best restaurant scenes I've ever
seen in television the most awkward
mexican restaurants pains between the
family so it was another good episode
it's been a good time this episode again
was like last week a little bit and I
mean a whole lot happens maybe within
the episode was that doesn't mean it's a
bad episode it's just that it's just
very few things that happen within the
episode yeah I think it's weird though
because I think people a lot more
forgiving of breaking bad for doing that
rises there's other shows that we like
we're walking by or walk Empire or even
game thrown some times where it is a
slower pace in but a lot of stuff is
happening underneath right and that's
what Breaking Bad is doing this season
and I think it's great but I think
people are more forgiving of Breaking
Bad doing as other [ __ ] yeah yeah I
don't know but yeah when you said
restaurant scene at first I thought
you're talking about oh yeah that bezar
good one too I i consider it's like
they're tarantino scene right you know
like here's this guy telling a story i
was two friends you know and obviously
they didn't really reveal what the
importance of that was but there must be
something with like the blood on his
yeah i mean ii flush the toilet and it
didn't quite the coming i'm assuming
they're coming back from that massive
shooting they had so with a methylene
right so maybe a couple seasonal track
him back to the diner and then
I don't know if that's going to happen
but I mean Gilligan's great just
planning those little seeds they're like
oh is that gonna be a clue an
investigation who knows yeah but yeah
the the scene that you were talking
about the restaurant scene with a with a
hank it Maurice Tyler walls yeah that
was really awkward I thought it was
funny with the the waiter always coming
in interrupt because it's it's kind of
true we're like obviously we aren't
having those type of conversations now
that big of conversation but there are
some times when you go a restaurant
maybe I don't know you're fighting with
your girlfriend or something like that
or there's something else going on
awkwardness awkwardness and then there's
a waiter just not knowing you know
they're driving their jobs that good but
they're kind of like in the way right
those really good that was set up I mean
attention was great i loved hank stair
gate one of the best just stare downs of
wall every time they kept they showed I
me just as angry look just looking at
that was awesome no it's not a great
scene I mean all the just great actors I
mean great actors just doing what they
do doing great things I mean especially
Hank and Walter and their dynamic I mean
Walter just you don't believe many more
like he just talks and says all this
crap and I like that Jesse actually
called him out in this episode and said
can you just basically space saying Kate
used to be real with me for like 10
seconds I mean Walt he can't do that I
don't even know what he say any well
he's not being real to anyone no it's
like tells Skyler what she wants to hear
he tells Walt Jr what he wants to hear
tell Jesse tells Hank like whatever he
thinks is that they're gonna be the best
outcome and for ourselves yeah I think
he's going for but you know the him and
Skyler a you know made that video that
yeah they're still sticking together
that that video basically puts Hank in a
place where it's like now he can't do
anything right what can he do all right
I mean he can kind of like try and find
the evidence on his own nope there's no
way he can bring it to the DA anymore I
mean those other great scene 2 again
like when I say nothing happened and I
say something nothing happened in the
episode because of course like boardwalk
empire's a lot of stuff going on
underneath like Game of Thrones a lot of
layers to a lots going on it's just not
action
whatever last five minutes of right less
of it so I mean that scene with Hank and
you're just watching that video of
Walter confessing the the false
confession that was a great scene well
because it's a believable story that
Hank is telling her to Hank a what is
telling I mean if you're the deal why
basically yeah oh you would think like
oh it's not him he's not the Masters
know it's a racial chemistry teachers to
get it right is we don't like this guy
Hank looks like he would be the guy who
did he's a DEA agent he has inside
information he knows how the cops think
it makes sense that he would I mean yeah
it makes sense and then what we find out
that now Hank said this that's the last
nail in the coffin I mean he you know
they would you spend a hundred seventy
seven thousand dollars in medical bills
or something like that so now they're
tied into China does now that money that
drug money has been paid for his
recovery and also like the way Walt tied
in the whole like assassination attempt
on on on Hank yeah how oh yeah that
tease that you know the kingpin and that
that's why they went after it makes
sense but his story Walt story is more
believable than the truth write the
story that Walt tells in that video is
more believable than what actually
happened and what also is a guy that you
tend to just because of Brian Krenz
performance pity him more yes Hank's got
that stern like you know confident alpha
male type thing going where's Hank or
Walt is kind of weaker and crying you
know and he just he's I can't say he's a
good actor because of course Bryan
Cranston actor but his character Walter
White is a good actor like he's good at
portraying these emotions and you
believe him you think he's being honest
yeah that's that I think that's his
greatest skill is it faking emotions
yeah I mean at this point we really
don't know what waltz think right now
because he's he's different people to he
himself is a different person to
different people right and he you know
you and his son like he was Anita
discuss it Walt Jr I mean that scene was
crazy and likely didn't you know like
basically making it so he wouldn't go
all right he didn't tell him that his
Kench was back because he cared about
his son's feelings it was so that he
would feel bad about leaving him and
went over to his aunt Marie's yeah
that's yeah he's just using him
yeah it's not good parenting parents out
there do not follow ultraoids example
yeah um but so yeah I mean we you know
we end with Jesse you know finding out
and obviously now maybe he'll team up
with Hank mm-hmm but even if he does I'm
still not sure if it's enough for Hank
to go to the DA with ya cuz cuz I think
Jesse in the eyes of the DA is not a
credible witness no way like he might be
like okay this guy he just wants to get
out of jail time he's gonna say all this
stuff about you know his mental state
he's he's just not all there right now
yeah Jesse I mean he's he's he's a
little bit out there and me just went
punch soul beat up Saul I mean he's on a
rampage putting gasoline and you know
Walters house and maybe possibly burning
it down so i don't know i don't i think
i agree that think jesse is not gonna be
a credible witness yeah but i think he
will team up with Hank in order to take
down Walt lesser of two evils he doesn't
like Hank necessarily but Hanks not as
evil as what a quote unquote evil as
Walt is just dies anyway yeah and then
the whole like thing when Saul was
selling Jesse on you know like a new
life well saw Ann Woll were like I'm
like okay well I think this is Walt
hadsall do that for him and that's why
he was in Connecticut and right and
whatnot yeah we still don't know what
he's coming back for though ya know what
the whole ordeal is right I kind of
assume like you said I thought that
maybe jesse was gonna go away though
wherever kind of new hampshire ever they
were and maybe maybe what would go meet
him out there later i thought that was
that was setting it up but obviously you
know he didn't take it he's staying in
town as far as we know so yeah I wonder
I'm still curious we're what three
episodes in yeah 9 10 11 a-3 episodes in
so we're getting to the halfway point of
the season I wonder when Walt is going
to go out east and when that's going to
happen maybe after the showdown with
jesse has got to be a showdown with
Jesse it has to happen at some point I
think I think it's gonna happen yeah
alright guys so that's what we thought
of the episode let us know your thoughts
and what you think of uh you know what's
gonna happen like do you think Jesse's
gonna team up with Hank it's gonna go
zone way I'd
now you can post your comments on this
video tube video which is a our YouTube
channel which is think Carol pro make
sure you subscribe our website think
hero com doesn't find us on Twitter i'm
at griffin de and i am at think hero and
we also have a Facebook page that's a
facebook.com slash think hero fans